Okay, Michael. So, I just gave you, you know, one
particular way you might do filtering. But let's see if
we can expand on that a little bit and come
up with some similar ways we might do wrapping. Okay?
>> Sure.
>> Okay so, I just gave an example of
a kind of filtering you might do through decision trees.
But really what I'm doing there is I'm defining
some criterion. And in this case it was information gain.
>> Right.
>> This is the way that I will, this is
the function that I will use to evaluate the usefulness
of a subset of features. How much information does that
feature give me about a class label? Can you think
of any other kind of filtering criteria we might use?
>> So, I don't know, variance. Like so, I want features that have
lots of different values. That'll do
something similar to information gain, I suspect.
>> M'kay. Yep. I like that one. So, we might call that variance.
Or actually another version of that would be entropy. And, there's tons of
ways to do this. Right, so, there's, there's something called the G index which
is a kind of diversion of entropy. There's variance, as you telling me
here that you're trying to pick features that show up a lot. Anything else?
>> I could imagine running a neural net and
then pruning away any input features that have low weight.
>> Okay. How would we describe that? That's that's
actually a kind of information gain too right?
Because if the neural network doesn't need it, then
somehow it doesn't seem to be terribly useful.
In fact why don't we just write that down.
>> Oh, I have another one.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So, if there's features that are linearly dependent
on other features then maybe get rid of them.
>> So you want independent features?
>> Yeah.
>> Or maybe we'll say non-redundant.
>> Oh, but in this,
in this kind of of linear algebraic sense.
>> Right. So if I have feature. Let's say x2
which turns out to be equal to, you know, x1 plus
x3 then I should probably get rid of x2. Is that what you're suggesting?
>> Sure, yeah, that's that is what I'm saying.
>> Okay, and that makes sense because I don't need x2.
>> Well, in principle it gives, yeah as you
said redundant information. But it also is the case that, for some
learners like neural nets, it shouldn't really,
you'll feel the difference. For things
like decision trees, it might matter though because having it, having those
sums together in one place could be more useful to split on.
>> That's true, but I do think you said
something important there, which, you said it shouldn't feel
the difference. You're defining whether this is good or
bad in terms of whether it helps you to learn.
But if we can get rid of a feature, then we save, as
we get rid of features, we save exponentially on the need for data.
>> Yes. So as long as it doesn't
make the learning problem harder, that's a good thing.
>> Right. So long as it makes the learning problem easier, in terms of the
amount of data you need, it's a win, up until the point where it makes
the learning problem harder because you don't
have enough features to do the actual learning.
And there's a bunch of these. And I
think all of these are probably good answers.
You could think of all kinds of statistical tests or
relevance. I mean basically are built in here these are
all different ways of doing the same thing which is
figuring out which features you need in order to do learning
by some generic criteria. I do want to point out
that something like Entropy doesn't even depend on the labels.
Where something like Information Gain which is a kind of
conditional Entropy, doe's depend upon knowing the labels. What about wrapping?
How would you go about doing the wrapping? So we
got a bunch of different ways we might do filtering. What
are sort of the way in which you could imagine doing
a wrapping? You got some learning, don't know what it is.
You got a bunch of features you want to search over those,
pass those features on to the learner and see how well
it does. But you don't want to pay an exponential cost,
by looking at all possible subsets. What might you imagine doing?
>> Well, so, I mean we've already talked about a bunch of algorithms that can
search, that aren't necessarily exponential. So various kinds of local search
and" hill climbing" could be a way of doing the search part.
>> Hmm, I like that. Let's write that down, "Hill Climbing". Now when you
say Hill Climbing, you really mean like
a gradient, a regular deterministic gradient search?
>> Hmmmmmmmmm, yeah. I mean, I guess I was thinking
of something where what does the search algorithm does is
it tells the learning algorithm here's the features to try
to use. The learning algorithm runs and it comes back with
some kind of error. Presumably, on how that validate
data otherwise, we run the risk of over fitting.
>> Fair.
>> And it gives a number back and then the, the
search algorithm uses that to decide what subset to try next.
Okay so you imagine that it's going to jump in some gradient
directly, or is it going to have to do something like randomize optimization.
>> I think it would have to, yeah I mean like, randomized optimization.
>> Okay so, in general we can
take almost everything we just did,
and the last lesson on randomized optimization
and apply it here, so then we might just say. Just do random.
>> Oh, I see. So could be, could be mimic.
It could be, genetic algorithms. It could be simulated annealing length.
>> Right. So you can think of, you can do randomized optimization.
And that's going to be important precisely
because we want to solve, this exponential problem.
We don't want that to be an issue. Okay that makes sense. Now
we've already thrown out exhaustive search
where we look at all possible features
because, again, that's exponential. Is there anything else you can think of? I'm
thinking of one more, so let's see if you can read my mind.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And really, when I say I'm thinking of one more, I'm thinking of two more.
>> Oh. That's, that are not randomized
optimization algorithms, but they're not going to somehow search.
>> Mm-hm.
>> A star?
>> Yeah, but that's not what I was thinking.
>> Oh. I give up.
>> I'll give you a hint. You could go forward or you could go backward.
>> EM.
>> [LAUGH] No. No. No. No. Although I like that.
>> ME?
>> [LAUGH] That wouldn't be forward or backward, would there? No,
I'm thinking of exactly a forward sequential selection and backward elimination.
>> I don't think I know what that means.
>> Oh. So
let's talk about that then.